Mining is one of the most dangerous professions
in the world, and while advances in technology
and safety protocols have certainly eased
the load that these hardened laborers endure,
it still remains a daring, backbreaking endeavor,
where accidents do happen, and your safety
is never one hundred percent guaranteed. But
mining is also a less common profession in
the United States today, with mines incorporating
more technology and less overall manual labor.
But it wasn’t always that way. In the 19th
and early 20th centuries, mining companies
employed hundreds of thousands of workers
across the country. Before large machinery
could mine surface pits and maneuver large
scale explosives from a safe distance, mining
was done manually, performed by teams of thousands
of workers tirelessly slaving in the dark,
digging for precious resources such as coal
or limestone, all while being underpaid, overworked,
and continually endangered on the job.
Mines were operated by mining companies, who
often took a large cut of a miner’s paycheck.
A 1902 account of a coal miner’s paycheck
claimed a $1.60 daily salary for a 10 hour
shift. Even when adjusted for inflation today,
that only comes out to $4.50 an hour, which
is below the United States minimum wage. And
some of that money would be taxed, or given
to the company for providing housing for the
miners families in company towns located adjacent
to the mines. While some companies were better
than others in terms of safety, unionizing
and demanding better pay or conditions was
frowned upon, and there was always the risk
of being kicked out of the town by the company
if you were caught attempting to do so. Because
of the demand and the cost of living, boys
as young as age 9 worked in mineshafts in
grueling conditions - this treatment was a
driving force in necessitating child labor
laws. And worst of all, accidents in the mines
were all too common in the early 20th century.
Mining involves the usage of explosives to
carve out new sections of rock to mine, and
if something went wrong, it could have resulted
in a cave-in, the complete collapse of a mining
tunnel or the surrounding rock, where dozens
or potentially even hundreds of miners could
be injured or worse. You had to work in complete
darkness, save for a few well placed torches,
push a cumulative thousands of pounds of materials
every day, and contend with the ever present
risk of a gas leak, which could suffocate
workers in a cramped, narrow shaft or even
result in an explosion when coming into contact
with the materials used during blasting. In
1917, 2,696 coal mining deaths were recorded
as a result of various causes. And that was
just one year of many. The underground has
claimed countless lives as a result of human
greed prioritizing profits and material output
over safety. It’s an area of nature we were
never truly meant to interact with, and the
sheer number of things that can go wrong in
a mining operation proves that. With all of
this death, danger, and darkness, it’s no
wonder that the mining industry is the center
of a blood-curdling anomaly that caught the
attention of the SCP Foundation. Today on
SCP Explained, we’ll be taking a look at
SCP-2951, an anomaly given the elusive codename
of “10,000 Years”. It will, as the channel’s
name implies, all be explained in due time.
The year is 1944. The Lemon Quarry, a limestone
mine located near Guthrie, Indiana, is like
countless others in the country. It’s owned
by the B.G Hoadley Mining Group, a company
that would soon find themselves with one less
mine to manage, and a lot of information to
cover up and destroy. Up until now, the operation
was proceeding smoothly, with the quarry’s
limestone deposits providing rich beds of
materials to export and sell, but all of that
was about to change. On August 23rd, 1944,
an earthquake occurred directly underneath
the Lemon Quarry. Seismic activity in Indiana
is strange enough, due to the area’s solid
limestone foundation and lack of fault lines,
but it was about to get a whole lot stranger.
Naturally, the company sent in an exploratory
team to assess the damage of the structure,
fearing that their limestone deposits were
caved-in or destroyed in the process. Three
hours later, the team returned to the surface,
reporting that an important access tunnel
had collapsed entirely. The tunnel was a necessary
section of the mineshaft, and the company
supervisors couldn’t afford to lose it,
so a larger team of workers were ordered to
clear the debris from the tunnel using their
hands and as much large machinery as they
could fit into the narrow shaft. During this
operation, another strange earthquake occurred,
causing a tunnel to collapse behind the crew
clearing the access tunnel.
The quarry was sent into a panic. Another
team was sent in to remove debris and attempt
to free the initial clearing crew. After four
hours of tireless work, they were successful,
and the clearing crew was saved, but the original
access tunnel was still blocked. This is when
it gets strange. The crew also reported that,
due to the earthquake shifting the cavern,
a new tunnel, one that hadn’t been cut by
the mining group and was not charted in the
company’s records, was opened. During exploration
of this newly discovered tunnel, it was described
as being smoothly cut, and descending on a
slight decline. The mining company speculated
that this may have been a tunnel cut by a
mining group prior to the quarry’s purchase
by B.G Hoadley that wasn’t properly recorded.
They hoped it would connect around to the
primary, still-blocked tunnel, and so they
assembled another team of 23 men to use the
new passage to access the rear of the blockage
and determine whether or not the use of explosives
to gain re-entry into the blocked tunnel was
viable.
And this is where the details of the story
run short. Sometime afterwards, there was
a third round of seismic activity, this time
collapsing the mine’s entrance tunnel. Over
the next three days, teams above ground removed
rubble and debris covering the entrance, and
the company’s supervisors attempted to contact
the men located underground using a telephone
cable line that ran into an access shaft in
the mine. On the evening of the third day,
just when the company was preparing to request
aid from other mining groups in the area,
an unknown individual emerged from the secondary
shaft and made it to the surface. What happened
next is unknown, but due to their collection
of information regarding the Lemon Quarry
incident, the Foundation discovered a single
telegraph, wired from the quarry to the mining
company’s head offices in Louisville. It
read:
26 8 1944
Mine abandoned. Tunnels remain collapsed.
23 lost.
One of them came up the shaft. We tossed it
back down. Wasn't right.
Sometime after this, B.G Hoadley sold the
quarry, where it sat abandoned for decades,
and the events that occurred there remaining
hidden and forgotten until June 4th, 1998,
when low seismic activity was detected outside
of Foundation facility Site-81. Foundation
geologists were dispatched to assess the situation,
but were unable to determine much information,
including where the activity was coming from.
Two weeks later, a missing person report was
filed with local law enforcement, where a
15 year old boy disappeared after he and his
friends were trespassing in the Lemon Quarry.
While search efforts were conducted, the boy
remained missing. But during those searches
of the quarry, it was discovered that there
was an unsealed shaft located beneath the
mine’s above ground maintenance building
that led directly into the mine itself.
A rescue team was lowered into the shaft,
after all, it was possible that the boy could
have fell in and was still down there. But
due to the unexpected depth and length of
the access tunnel, the team had to wait until
longer ropes and safety harnesses were available.
The estimated depth of the tunnel was 120
meters, but the rescue team reassessed those
numbers after exploring the shaft, finding
them to be closer to 240 meters.
Still, the boy was unable to be found, and
the rescue crews reported feeling agitated,
as well as having doubts about their perception
of the mine around them. The five man rescue
crew reported there being seven or eight members
of the team, and one of the men reported that
they were in the mine to “look for gold”
and not the missing boy. After 43 minutes,
the team went radio silent, and ceased responding
to communications. Above ground, the teams
retracted their tether, but found that more
was being retracted than had gone down the
shaft. After retracting 400 meters of tether,
the winch was overwhelmed, and came to a stop.
It was these events that alerted the SCP Foundation
about potential anomalous activity in the
Lemon Quarry. The Foundation took control
of the rescue efforts, posing as a federal
search and rescue team. They were successful,
somewhat, retrieving two of the five men,
who were still connected to their tethers,
but less connected to their minds. One man
became violent when he reached the surface,
and began to physically attack Foundation
personnel, believing he was still deep within
the mine. The other man was originally believed
to be comatose, but after twenty minutes of
unconsciousness, he began speaking unintelligibly,
in a voice that wasn’t his own, but one
of the other men he went down into the shaft
with. The three other men did not surface.
Two of their tethers returned with the ropes
clean cut on their side. The third was clearly
sliced with jagged pieces of rock, and covered
in human blood across a significant portion
of its length.
After the two retrieved men were transported
to Site-81, the Foundation quickly administered
amnestics to all non-Foundation personnel,
and developed a cover story for the events
that occurred. The Lemon Quarry was classified
as SCP-2951 for the interior of the mine being
subject to irregular spatial and temporal
anomalies. A historical probe into the B.
G. Hoadley company and the 1944 incident was
launched, and inside SCP-2951, the Foundation
dispatched four members of the mobile task
force trotter-5, a squad named Hell’s Heroes,
to further analyze what was occurring in the
underground. The team entered the mine through
the secondary access shaft, and was ordered
to spend no longer than forty minutes in the
mine.
There was, though it remained unlikely, the
slight chance that they could recover the
three lost search and rescue members and the
missing boy, though the Foundation wasn’t
holding their breath, knowing very well how
strange, mysterious, and dangerous anomalous
locations can be.
The task force descended, and after a quick
mic check to determine that their recording
equipment was working, they moved further
down the shaft. It was dark, and unnaturally
deep. After reaching 120 meters, they came
to a stop, an area where they could walk around.
This contradicted the 240 meter depth reported
by the rescue team. The task force looked
for tether hooks, or any other physical evidence
from the original team, but they only found
footprints. Moving around the dark, winding
area, they began to explore. It wasn’t long
before the operatives became disoriented.
Keeping in mind their 40 minute limit, one
operative started the clock, and the captain
ordered him to let him know whenever 10 minutes
had passed. While exploring, they noticed
two tether lines up against a wall of rock.
They took pictures and moved on, descending
deeper. The timekeeping soldier reported that
they clocked in ten minutes, but the others
felt like it had been longer than that. Coming
to a narrow, tight access shaft, the team
determined that they needed to move single
file.
While significant time was passing, the timekeeper
only reported that they had been underground
for 17 minutes. Being skilled in anomalous
exploration, the team members realized that
there was something wrong, and that this was
most likely a temporal anomaly. But that wasn’t
all, the team began seeing flashes of light
in the distance, and hearing noises beneath
them. They made the decision to pull out of
the shaft, and after moving towards the light
in front of them, thinking it was from the
surface, they found that they were no closer
to leaving than they had been when they entered.
The clock still displayed a time of 17 minutes,
and trying to figure out where they were in
the shaft was becoming next to impossible.
As if it couldn’t get any worse, the team’s
flashlights and headlamps began dying out.
Now, the task force was completely in the
dark, and they could only move downwards.
They weren’t sure where they were going,
but they were certain that it was down. The
sensations of the cavern were growing stronger.
Strange smells. Something unclear written
on the walls of the cave. The clock now displayed
13 minutes. The operatives began repeating
themselves, stating the phrase “Too long
in the fire.” over and over again. It was
a nightmare, but the team soldiered onward,
dazed by the shaft’s anomalous effects.
Just when they were able to see the surface
light again, they noticed something. There
were more members of the team than they originally
started with. Three of them. Mimicking the
others' voices, wearing their uniforms. One
of the entities appeared as if it were on
fire, smoke smoldering from its back. Repeating
that phrase over and over again. The captain
ordered his men to shoot at the imposters,
firing at them in the dark. But the shots
missed, and accidentally hit something that
caused a violent combustion, causing all recording
devices to cut out, and the Foundation to
remove the task force from the shaft entirely.
All four members were recovered, and given
a medical evaluation. The entities that impersonated
and attacked the task force, however, were
unable to be found. During an interview with
one of the recovered operatives, he claimed
that the team was losing track of time, but
was shocked to discover that while their recorders
were active for a total of five hours and
thirty three minutes, they only spent 19 minutes
total in the mine altogether. A strange, anomalous
time dilation effect between the surface and
the underground. The operative was unable
to determine the point when the entities,
clad in their armor and badges, joined up
with the group. The interviewing doctor offered
the operative an amnestic, but he declined,
stating that he’ll only need it if he’s
still dreaming about the entity screaming
at him with his own voice months later.
While the Foundation’s exploration of SCP-2951
revealed the anomalous effects of the shaft,
the historical investigation also bore fruit.
They learned the story of the 1944 collapse
that caused B.G Hoadley to sell the mine,
but they also learned another important piece
of information about the Lemon Quarry. The
Foundation recovered a contact list in an
abandoned Hoadley office that allowed the
Foundation to make contact with Gorman Ellis,
a retired Hoadley investigator who was cooperative
and willing when met with Foundation agents
knocking on his door. During the interview,
the Foundation learned that Ellis was originally
a foreman with the company, and both his father
and his grandfather were associated with the
higher ups at Hoadley. When asked about the
Lemon Quarry, Ellis said that while he never
worked there, he did spend time there cleaning
it up after the company had shut the mine
down. Ellis recognized how strange an earthquake
in the area was, but couldn’t put his finger
on anything strange about the collapse. He
knew they lost a few men during it, but the
incident wasn’t talked about much. He told
the agent to attempt to get a hold of a man
by the last name of Barnes, who was also involved
in the cleanup and had contacts with the company
who bought out the land after Hoadley sold
it. Just when the Agent was about to leave,
however, Ellis remembered another piece of
information.
The cleanup that he worked on had over three
dozen men working at the same time, but Ellis
said that it was the quietest job he had ever
worked. In fact, he wasn’t sure if a single
one of them said anything to him the entire
time that he was there.
The Foundation received a number of personal
documents from Ellis’s contact, Barnes,
in the form of letters that detailed the Lemon
Quarry’s sale to Kervier International.
The incident was described as a typical cave-in,
but also detailed that strange men in suits
appeared at the scene weeks after, asking
questions and attempting to “listen to the
rocks”, according to the letter. After this,
Kervier International, a mining group that
the Foundation has so little information on
that they believe it is anomalous itself,
purchased the Lemon Quarry. A letter addressed
to barnes read as follows:
I saw it myself, Jeremiah. I saw something
that was like a man crawl out of that hole.
It smoked and burned and cried out in another's
voice. It was a thing pulled straight from
the Pit itself, I have no doubt.
That man from Geist said as much himself,
that the pillars that support the world will
crack and crumble, and the foundation will
become loose. What lies below will become
accessible, and its might will fall upon the
meek. I saw it with my own eyes, I know it
is true.
I still hear its words, Jeremiah. "Ten thousand
years." Screaming like a wild dog, shrieking
like it was cornered. "Ten thousand years
in the fire."
In 2003, Ellis passed away, with the Foundation
seizing his assets. During this process, the
Foundation discovered a letter addressed to
an unknown recipient, revealing that he knew
more about the Lemon Quarry than he had led
on. Its contents are chilling, reading:
It was twenty-three in total. Twenty-three
of those poor boys got stuck behind that wall.
We could hear them for days, shouting behind
those rocks while we sat around and did nothing.
Have you ever been down in a mine during a
blackout? Let me tell you about it. First
there is a moment of panic, when everybody
scrambles to figure out what's going on. Then,
as things calm down, you try to get your eyes
adjusted to the dark around you. But you never
get adjusted, because there's nothing to see.
It's not like dark at night, where you can
see stars and the moon, or a streetlight.
There is no light in a mine during a blackout.
There's nothing to see down there.
Then you start to hear things. Some boys will
hear voices, or animals, or any number of
things that just aren't there. Some will wander
off and get lost, they won't follow the ropes
back up. Some will fall in a shaft or into
a crevice, and you'll never see them again.
Then it gets real quiet.
I got to see that tunnel they found before
the cave-in. Very strange. Didn't look dug
by tools, not proper. Didn't even have time
to string up lights in it, to see where it
went. I don't know what's down there. Anyway,
all I'm saying is, I haven't thought much
about Hell but I sure think we deserve it.
Whatever happens to those boys, as long as
they’re down there, is our fault. It's our
fault for doing nothing.
And the dark changes people.
Now go watch “SCP-1179 - Centralian Fire
Demon” and “SCP–2935 – O, Death”
for more possible mine and cave-dwelling anomalies
from SCP Explained!